Okay hello everyone,
welcome to today's work program,
so today we are going to discuss the exam conducted by CBSE on
17th,
what type of
questions were asked and what all.
What kind of answers should we have given
and what should be the answers? So let's
move ahead.
All the children who are connected are
very welcome and
okay
so many children have joined now
as we can see on the screen.  Let us
try to tell you how all your papers went. Okay, have
you all solved all your papers? Let
us move towards the paper
and this paper is in front of us which is now visible. If we had
come in today's paragraph
then the following  Read the passage carefully. The
first beat in section N is the
unread passage.
Children and this
instruction here is to read this passage
carefully and
choose the correct answer to these questions and from
option.  We have to choose and answer, so
let's see some of the paragraphs given to you. There are
constant threats on the Earth.
Every year thousands of
its bodies come towards the Earth
and sometimes even scientists
feel threatened by it.  So scientists keep finding
scientific ways to deal with the threat posed by them, which are the
threat they pose to us and what
scientists keep
doing to save them, like NASA is thinking
whether nuclear weapons can kill us.  But
we can rock any dangerous object before it hits the earth, can our
friends'
light be rocked first and
destroy them before that, can the
direction of their object be changed with rocket boosters etc.
Both of them did
not get much success on these two solutions,
but NASA scientists
also felt that what would happen if a very dangerous
object collides with the Earth,
then what?  Brother, what will happen if it collides with the Earth?
What will happen if humans on Earth are destroyed?
A solution has come from an American entrepreneur.
Whose source has it come from? Brother,
is America a dummy? A solution has come from his side.  So, what is it
which is quite interesting, the
founder has only one mission to
create Manav B Bank, to create Manav B Bank and
in other words, this bank will be
preserved as if its DNA,
this bank will be established on a few days if
on this earth.  If any human being dies
then
this bank will help in starting the human civilization i.e. food means
a human B bank i.e. brother, it has become a thing
that someone advised to use human beings also as a B.  It was a
very interesting
advice and what he did was that brother, where is this
beach bank, where should we do it,
that if the earth is ever destroyed, the world comes to an end,
then we can take seeds from there and
use them
and make DNA from human cells, human blood
and so on.
What is the need of kissing human civilization? Brother, you are right in seeing
that here human DNA should be the right
answer because human DNA itself has been mentioned
here as the life of the
human being. Let us take the second question to save the human beings.  What is the life-threatening effort made in the field
called,
i.e. the person who said this and what was said about the
effort to save humans?
What has been said? Brother, option A says
interesting and thoughtful. Now critics and thoughtful.
Interesting and thoughtful,
interesting and thoughtful, then what should be the
question number 3 which is the
following statement, this question was asked here, here,
sometimes we in this and R,
sometimes there is statement and sometimes there is
also explanation.  First there may be the
explanation and second there may be its statement.
First there may be the statement and second there may be the explanation.
Sometimes both the
statements should be kept at their place. We should
read them very carefully like
here I am reading the following statement.
And read both R carefully,
that is, it says that you should read A and R very carefully.
After this,
choose any one correct option from the given options.
Okay, let's agree with
you.  There are moons and colors
and many more. Ok right, let's see first.
Statement one says that every year thousands of bodies
come to the earth and there is a
scientific threat to their bodies. This is true which
we have read in the paragraph. Now when we
read the paragraph.  So, children, what had you read
that these thousands of years
come in thousands of bodies, due to which the scientists
consider it as a threat, the earth has been a
very dangerous mother and the second one, now what is the
second one and what is it, brother?  If the
objects coming towards the Earth can be
successfully destroyed by authentic weapons, that is,
food means
we
can successfully destroy it with nuclear weapons, then both the things are
true, what was mentioned in the paragraph, then
why do we have the option now?  If we give then statement A and
Karan and both are wrong
and but Karan and
B are wrong what to do brother statement this is right and the other one is
wrong but both the things are right there
ok come on
you guys are also watching the comments
I am and
what about the third one  What C does is say Statement A
is wrong but statement A is correct
Statement A is wrong and reason A is correct but
both things are correct So now which one is the saving option
children last option i.e. Statement A and
reason And both are correct and reason  And the statement
gives only one correct explanation. The right answer
will be the last one. Okay,
so let us move ahead to the next
question and that is, where was the
Manav B Bank planned to be established,
then where were we planning to establish it?  It
is in NASA, on Earth, on Mars and
on Chandra, then Paragraph
Next Question Question No. 5 Based on the passage,
what is not the reason for thinking of scientists, that is,
based on the passage, which of the following is not the reason for thinking of scientists,
then its body
Colliding with the Earth is the right thing. The
condition of the Earth becoming devoid of humans was
also their concern. Thirdly,
destroying their body before it collides with the Earth was
also their concern. We, who are their
body, which is coming towards us, are ours.
How to make them destroy us on Earth?
All of you must have also given the same question.
Let us move towards the next question.
Question number 2. Read the following passage
carefully. Here also there is an unknown passage
which we have to read very carefully and answer
its questions.  If we want to answer, then the
Department of Pediatrics of a famous Ayurvedic Science Institute of the country conducted a study of 660 children
for 2 years. In this study,
children up to 5 years of age were
included. It was found that these children sing for
more than an hour.  Time spent on mobile,
yesterday the time spent on mobile and TV was 5 hours, not only this,
their parents also spend about 6.5 hours
on various gadgets, that is, in the present
time, where we are trapped in the mobile, the same
things are said in this paragraph.  It has been said that
from small children to older children,
they are spending more time and their parents have also become
addicted to wireless gadgets, different gadgets, okay devices. If it is a kind of
addiction and this is a kind of addiction today.
Now we can live without eating without gadgets,
but we cannot live without gadgets or without mobile
recharge, this is very true, OK sir, but
if attention is not paid in time,
then this habit
will become a big problem for the future generations also.  Shakti is ok, electronic
devices should not be given. Ok, so
ban is power. World Health Organization's
touch advice is that i.e. whatever is the world's
advice. What is brother's advice?
Gadgets or electronic devices should
not be given in the hands of children up to 2 years of age, even up to
5 years.  Even at the age of one year, their
screen time should not be more than 1 hour. The
viewing time should not be more than one hour.
Okay, but in affluent homes, that is, those
who are happy and prosperous and who do not have any kind of
weakness.  Well, it is seen in the houses
that they start linking it with their
status i.e. the
more gadgets they have, the more money they have,
then they consider their status to be our status,
our children have a mobile,
I have a mobile, everyone has a mobile.  The
brother who is doing less in our house also has a
mobile. While doing this, he forgets that
he is not caring for his children for today. By doing this,
what are those parents doing? They
are spoiling not only their today but also their tomorrow.
So let's question this.  Let us look at the
first question which is, which of the following
statements can be said as the basis of C of the passage,
then which are the statements that the lesson of this passage
can give us, then the first is that
electronic devices are not used.  Should be
okay. Second is that there should be
limited use of electronic work. Third is that
devices should not be added to more than the status.
Fourth says that electronic
devices should not be used.
So, the first thing that has been said is that the
use of electronic devices should be limited.  If you don't do it, then today's
date will not work. Today, everything from banking to whether
children will go to
school tomorrow or not, all these things can be
known through your mobile, so I
think we can avoid it by
limiting the use of electronics.
Okay, so this is the right answer, children,
you can go with this. The next
question is, which
tendency of the parents is unfair for their children,
then which tendency of the parents
is unfair for their children?
Being very rich in resources, OK, that is,
they are rich in whatever resources they have,
let's move ahead, now in the next, they are
very rich in education, this is also
not right, linking gadgets with their status,
this is right because we have read.
In the paragraph, it is said that
not buying a gadget as per one's capacity, no, this is also
not working, then the right answer is C.
Option C is to assemble the gadget with one's own hand, which
we had read in the paragraph. Right Answer
Question No. 3: Consider the following statements.  That
is, here the statements are
given. Children, you have to read these four statements
and choose the right answer considering it.
So, what does the first statement say? Let
us read. I
got good sleep due to the use of gadgets before Sony.
Okay, before Sony, I got
good sleep by using gadgets.
Brother, I did not. I did not get good sleep. We stay awake throughout the night.
If we sit looking at the mobile,
then this habit is not a good thing. Second, it is
said that in today's marriage, gadgets have to do with their
status.  On the basis of this, the
second one is that at present the use of gadgets has become an
addictive society, this is also true
and the third one says that the last option says that
uncontrolled use of gadgets
is harmful for the future of children, which is so.
I think that Kha G G is the right answer.
Option A is not correct
because yesterday it is wrong. Option C is
said but all three are correct. The
last option
is the correct answer. We should go with this.
Let's move on to question number four.  On the basis of the passage, it is
because of giving electronic gadgets in the hands of small children. Okay, so what is
Karan Bhai, because of giving gadgets in the hands of small children, so
as we had read, let's
find the option here, what we had read is true
or not, children.  Where it is not
wrong, the demand for time is also wrong, the
show of prosperity is D. Right Answer: OK,
lack of time for children, that is, where the matter of show of prosperity, that is, of
adding status, has come,
hence the passage on the hands of small children.
Due to giving life electronic devices, which
is a show of affluence,
okay, it's fine, we are doing
more to show the demand for time, because with the passage of time, there are many
people who don't even have it, what do they even
do, if they roam around with mobile phones, then
we are demanding for the time.  And you people must have been paying attention to the
demand for time, but not everyone's,
and what is the importance of small children,
2 year old children,
here is the right answer to show off wealth, so let's
go to question number five, what is the shelter from
screen time, what is the shelter from screen time?
Brother, he
will spend time only on mobile, time spent only on TV,
then brother, do these three things, if all
three are screens, then the right answer is
appropriate. All three are OK, then the right answer option is the
right answer. Children, let
us look at question number 3 Rachna.  You
know the difference in sentences, that is,
we have come across grammar in your syllabus
and out of these, you will answer most of the questions. Let's take the
first question, whenever
Munni Babu used to sit down to study, he would come up with something or the other,
like a brother.  Do you know that an Egyptian
sentence
should have two words and two sentences? The first sentence
is incomplete. Whenever he sat down to read,
something must have happened. Let's move on to the
next question, which is Almora-
born Sumitranandan Paint started
writing poetry since childhood.  Had done,
then convert this sentence into a compound sentence.
So here
Sumitranandan, we have to change the sentence including this.
Children, here for the including sentence, brother,
we know that your teachers
must have told you that and and but because but but all these
words which are  To
join two simple sentences, there is some
Fevicol which we call and i.e.
Fevicol which joins two words together,
we call them and but but but that's
why
sometimes or and or  So here let us
see what is the word that connects two words,
brother, Sumitranandan Paint was born
in Almora and I have found out what I
told you, he
started poetry since childhood, so this option is the right
answer, we will see it.  Let's take it, I have
understood that this is the right answer, but still I will
read all three of the four below.
Sumit 15, related to Almora, has been
writing poems since childhood. Even the story here, I do
not think that this is a committee sentence, was
born in Almora.  K Karan
Sumitranandan Paint started writing poetry since childhood,
Lakhni started writing, so
here also I do not think that there are any
kind of connecting words nor
two words or two sentences are defined. Option given by
Sumit
who was born in Almora.  Tha Ab Ne Ab Now
Which statement in this sentence is not correct?
Brother
Amit, in a sentence two or more sentences are
joined by conjunctions. The correct thing is
that joining a compound sentence is done
by conjunctions only. Two
or more sentences are joined by conjunctions.  It can also be true
because and but because but that's why I
told you that joining two simple sentences
comes less in a close sentence, the third second which
says that a sentence has to be changed into another type of
sentence, the rest is also a matter of
fact.  It is as we say that sentence
conversion i.e. changing from simple sentence to Egyptian
sentence or converting from simple sentence to close sentence
or changing close sentence to Egyptian
sentence. In this sentence conversion ok
simple sentence has only one purpose and only one subject.  So it is
true that in
simple sentences there will be a purpose and
a subject. Okay, this too sir, this is
correct, but in the Egyptian sentence, the option has been given to
their sentence, it has its own independent position.
Brother, this is absolutely wrong.
Do not have any independent existence
because they are incomplete. Okay, as
Kabir Das ji says, now this sentence
is incomplete, something must have happened further. Okay, so this
option given is the correct answer. Let us
move ahead today. Question number four is the
following.  Which of the following sentences
is not a simple sentence? Now it remains to be said that which of the following
sentences is not a simple sentence, then the one that came before,
its monkey-like face
seems even more strange, its monkey-like face
seems even more strange, so this is not a simple sentence.  It
seems, let's see now, he
himself studies English in class 5th and 8th.
He studies English in class 5th and 8th by
himself.
I travel a lot but
he does not get the condition of the puzzle.
Well, the above sentence is a simple sentence and the second one is
also a simple sentence.  It is because we
can speak both of them without stopping. It has the same
purpose and the same legislator. His monkey-
like face looks even more strange. We
can speak without stopping. Date this sentence. This
is a simple sentence. It also has a purpose and a method.
Second, fifth.  And fifth, here you people might be
confused that something else has come but
you will not take any pause while speaking this sentence.
He himself studies fifth and eighth class
in English. Look, I have
not paused even a bit while speaking, here
I am the same.  When I have to study C, I used to travel a lot
but but but here
I had to stop as I said but but because but like
this but if the word A
goes and there should be two words like the first
word is independent, the first sentence which is
independent I very  He used to do tourism. This
sentence is the
second sentence. He does
not get the condition of the puzzle. He does not get the condition of the puzzle. The
sentence
felt sorry and Manmohan. This is also a simple sentence. So
option C is the right answer.
Now this is the fifth question. I am brother's
right.  I started taking unfair advantage of listening
to my elder brother. This is the question, I started
taking unfair advantage of my brother's tolerance.
What kind of sentence is this? Sister, I did not say that there should be a
method for only one purpose without stopping. If you
can say it then what would it be?  Brother, let's start a simple
sentence,
now the question is
based on number, here too there will be five questions
and after doing the answer, OK, let's
go to
question number first, which comes first.
Some students of class 7th and 8th tell us in their big question.
What is the underlined phrase here? So children.  If
you know about the phrase of drawing,
then what are the things here, what is here, the
line, which is indicated, this is the
line, here is the word student, is it
absolutely correct, the word student, which is a noun, it
is a common noun, so this word is  Which
is, when it is a common noun, then this will be the answer.
Brother, then the noun phrase will be band.
Some students of seventh and eighth class are common noun, therefore, it is a noun, pronoun, not an adjective, it will not be an adjective,
and it is an adverb, otherwise, therefore, the right
answer is divided as
this which is.  Let's move on to the next question.
Next
question, which is the big builders? Which part is this
from? Brother, yes,
now where is
a line taken from the lesson on being saddened by the sorrow of others, in which it is
said that the big builders are  For many years,
its land has been destroyed by pushing it back from the sea,
so here it is
written that in it, it is written that the big
builders, written in B, have pushed back their
land, written in G, and it is written as Gham.
Weapons have been, that is, this sentence has been
divided into 'Kar Bhagan', so now below is the
quotation that from the above mentioned adverbs,
adverb has been identified, brother,
what is
adverb? Brother, the one which tells the specialty of the verb is
called adverb, ok and noun is pronoun.
You already know that adjectives are used to describe the characteristics of something,
which we cannot cloud in any way.
Okay, so here we will see what was written earlier, brother,
what is the meaning of big builder, builder, builder, always in the end.  The
last thing you have to pay attention to is what to pay attention to is brother a noun is brother this a noun
okay by
pushing okay it seems let's go to the
ground this factor never asks
here so this action has no meaning this
weapon has been this verb  Okay, the
right answer is, I think, what
is the adverb? Brother, adverb.
Okay, so
in the option you will see only 'Yes, brother', only the
right answer. Now I don't feel the need to read 'Di' and 'Si' and 'Di'
because I have
got the right answer. Adverb.  Okay, so
B is only
glory,
so the verbs here are a little mistake, let's
go to option A, now in this the verb
children is always at the end of any sentence,
brother is at the end of any sentence and this is the
adverb. Okay, so the right answer is given,
let's move ahead.  Hum
Next Question: Master Pritam Chand had a
thin and slim body. What was Master Pritam Chand's lean and
muscular body and
in the sentence there is an underlined phrase.
Brother, there is no underline here. If you
look at the question paper, then perhaps
you are great in helping the thin and thin.
You are great in helping others,
brother. I told you to follow this word.
What is this word, brother, it is a pronoun. Do
you like it? I think you all would have given the same answer.
Let's move ahead. Next comes the
idiom.  On the other side, 6 questions will be asked
and if you have to answer any of these, then
which tax will you answer? First is the
idiom: Poison has been poisoned.
Now something seems to be poisonous to us, that is, it has
become very big. Okay, it has become very big.
Right answer is then.  Even if I give it to someone else, it does
n't feel very bitter. We don't say that
being very poisonous is not this. Having an influence on the world is
also not this. Okay, let's
move ahead. Let's
consider the following pairing. Till now,
here you guys have a little knowledge of the children.  I have a doubt
that when such a question comes, we have to
consider the pairing, that is, here
these types of things are not there,
you should see with whom the right match has been
made, like this, OK, now is this the right match or
not?  Is it right to meet or not? It is not right to
touch hands like this,
brother. Okay, it will be public here.
Touching does not mean the meaning of this idiom
is to take it out of the hand and fall down, brother, the
society is not like this,
this also does not happen.  It is not about taking it in your hands,
that is, whoever you kiss,
take this responsibility in your hands,
then I think that this pawn will be
very easily
welcomed by others, if you come to our house,
now let's look at the option of first one.  It is only
brother, this is wrong, only writer,
now let us move ahead to the next question
and from the following,
identify the appropriate idiom for the meaning of cheating and write it, then it
is suitable for cheating. Okay, so the first idiom is brother, what is it for cheating?  There
may be tears in the eyes brother, there may be tears in the eyes
which means feeling very sad.
We
second says that if dust is thrown in the eyes then the
party likes the joker police. Now when dust is thrown, nothing can be
seen and when
something is visible.  If you don't give it, then a thief runs away,
that is, I think it is right,
but I will also observe Chauth. Egg with
butter in its hand means that one is very lucky.
One is blind. Someone got butter in his hand, that
is, a bird.  That means you are very
lucky, but what has happened here is that you should be
evicted from the house for cheating, brother, it is not necessary to evict you from the house,
here
OK, after cheating, this is the
right answer son and you all might have done the same, I
hope, let's
go younger.  Seeing the carelessness of the brother, the elder brother made
him a slave,
elder brother,
we have to fulfill it, the
elder brother
gave us the option to take him by hand, right answer and here he used to take it, whenever
he came, what did the younger brother do, elder
brother and here  Used to take Khadi-Khoti, used to listen to
Okay, so
let's see next. To have
dominance is
appropriate from the following Muharram meaning to have dominance. Now to have dominance, to show
arrogance means to show
arrogance, to show pride, to
pull one's skin i.e. to harass someone.  That means
troubling him too much i.e. giving harsh
punishment, giving harsh punishment and removing the seat chandi, this
also comes under the provision of harsh punishment.
Right answer key has started speaking
because it has become famous either because
of the mafia or because of some domineering person.  If she speaks too much,
then dominance is her relief. We common
people do not blame anyone, so tell me the right answer. If you
come in my rank, then the
slave will go. If you come in my rank, then the slave will go, then
what will come brother? The story will end, the story will
not end.  If you come in my category then it will be
reduced, no brother thinks like this, will he
not think that if you come in my category, then the knot will be closed, the
knot will be closed, it is not like this, it is really
not right, so let's fit the second last one, if you
come in my category then it will be fine.  You will
sweat, that is, you will come to know
when I am at my level, you will
come to my class, you will come to know in ninth class, you will
sweat, then the right answer is given in this
option. If
we take questions based on society, then
five questions will be asked here also and  Out of the five,
you have to answer by doing tax. Here also
you are getting points by doing tax. Now
brother, which position is dominant in the society, then
that position in the society is first small and dominant,
we all know this in which the first position is
The word which is is a prefix, hence the
antecedent is the first one, the former man is the first one,
option A is the right answer, okay, let's go,
which compound will be there in war thing, brother,
when it comes to Yudhishthir, then
in my mind, in my mind or in the mind of all of us, brother Pandu.  The
name of Arjun's son and elder brother
was A Gaya, that is, that story of Mahabharata had come before us,
hence when something
becomes a rule for a particular person or
for a special person, then it goes,
where will the Bahuvrihi Samas go?  OK, let's go, who is
stable in the war, if Panduputra
or Arjun's elder brother
does it, then who will reduce it? Okay, let's say, out of the
following, which is the
appropriate example of Bahuvari society, brother,
what is the appropriate example of Bobby society, then the film producer,
then whose producer brother, film?  Creator of
OK Kalam merge brother in kiss Merge Kalam in Whose
form is the musician Musician is not a musician
Swayambhu Swayambhu kiss is called brother Swayambhu is
called God and this is the example of Bahuvari society
Right Answer OK Those who were born from ourselves
We all were born from ourselves
But only God is the self-manifested. Okay,
let's diagnose Daya.
In which option is the correct compound resolution and difference of the entire verse? Then the
demise of Daya is Tatpurush Samas Right Answer. Karmdharay Samas
read. Answer the following questions on the basis of the reader.
Let us see brother.
But what message does the sitting bird
give us? So what message does the bird sitting above give? If it is
taken from the top part, then
what message does it give? Life is mortal and
fleeting, one should be cautious of external invaders
and should take care of the inherited things.
Brother, all these things have been told in the story,
but what message does that
bird give? What message is it sending? Now it is
going into his mouth and coming out of his mouth. Till
yesterday, when this top was in use, then there were
posters of good heroes.  For example,
here the option given is the end of the tyrant, one day or the other it is
impossible, it is definitely great, due to the impossible it
definitely happens, that is, whatever happens
one day, one day, one day, it definitely becomes peaceful, that is why the
option is given, the right answer is ok, let's do
something.  People made a mistake.
Now let us see. Read the following statements
carefully. Out of these, we have to read all four statements one by one.
God himself helps his devotees at the time of selling.
Let us also see where and
on whom.  It is taken from
suicide,
God never
asks for help, sometimes he says, brother, give me strength, give me my
child, but you don't help me,
even if trouble comes to me, I
will control myself,
give me so much strength, God, this is wrong.  Do you
ever expect positive results of your actions from this time?
This is
also wrong. You should
not give up your self-confidence and effort in adverse circumstances. This is
right. Whatever the wicket situation may be, no matter
how the question paper came, but your
confidence and self-confidence go with it.
You should never give up. You should never be worried. You should
think, OK, let's solve this. You should
not doubt the existence of God in adverse circumstances.
Yes, it is true that we
remember God only in difficult situations
and circumstances.  We should never
doubt God, that is,
God does not help us.
Maybe we want to help but we are
not taking help. So brother, which
answer is right? This is wrong.  Will not
happen
What did Shailendra, a craftsman of the third class,
want? I want soul satisfaction, I
don't want money and vanity
because he stayed away from external ostentation. He
lives in the film world, but still he is
proud of his belonging to the tax fraternity of the film world.  Never accepted, he
only wanted to make one film in his life,
not to become famous,
not to make a hit film, not to earn money,
no one wants that for my mother's
peace, I wrote so many songs in my life yesterday.
If you write, I want a film to be made.
Whether it works or not, my soul is
satisfied. Is it the right answer? Okay,
immense wealth as
given by Jain's
De Part. What lesson do we learn from Jain's De Part? So
brother, Jain's  All of you must have read during the day that
we should never compete with a country bigger than us
or is it right
because in order to gain prestige from America,
what happened to the people there, they started
going through mental torture, OK, they became mental patients and
started muttering to themselves.  If you
start doing anything, then we should not do it. We should
only do it from a country smaller than our own. Brother, this is
also wrong. If we cannot do it with a big one then
why do it with a small one, then we should
not compete with anyone. What are we, my
own strength?  Recognize how far my friend has gone,
see how far I can go. We should
worry about the past and the future. Brother, we should
worry about the present more than the present. Only then will the
future be made. Let us leave the worries about the past and the future.  We should
worry about the present.
Okay, so whatever is troubling you today,
worry about today. Okay, so let us leave the worries about the past and the future. Bye,
what happened in the past, what will happen next, it does
n't matter what am I doing today,
what is my presentation today, so
given the option.  This D is the right answer. Okay, let
us move ahead.
Give the most appropriate answer to answer the following questions based on the exercise. Do
you all know what this
poem is?
You keep decorating
new convoys, the celebration of victory is after this celebration,
life is meeting death, take the shroud over your head,
friends, now the country is handed over to you friends, it is a
very good song
brother, the
option is there for the security of the country, the upliftment of the country.
For the expansion of the country and for the
development of the country, brother, this is what I think the
soldiers want. Brother, the soldiers want that
you went for the security of the country, so
option A is D. Right answer is OK, so here
option A is for the country.  Upliftment brother, this is the
upliftment of the country, if the country is safe, then the country
will progress like this. For the expansion of the country,
who is brother for the expansion of the
country? There are many people, the leaders are brothers for the development of the country,
Modi ji is there, okay everyone, let's
move ahead.  Let's talk about
tying a shroud on the soldier's head
because the end of his life is near.
Okay
Saini, the
end of his life is near. Let's
talk about tying a shroud on the soldier's head
because he is in a very injured condition. This wo
n't happen. First, a little c  Well, let's
look ahead, we talk about tying a shroud around a soldier's head
because the country
can stand up even in the face of death. This
seems to me the right thing. The story is stronger than the one above.
I
should have the option of feeling like this.  But we have to read the option,
we soldiers talk about shrouding the head
because doing this during the war
is an ancient mountain, brother, if it is not an ancient mountain,
then this is absolutely wrong. Now let's see
what is below brother, only
I said.  Tha OK Keval
[Music]
Right Answer Only
Poet is talking about which convoy to decorate,
so ever who is talking about which convoy to decorate
Brother, the one who identifies the logistics on the border, the
bhajan on the convoy's border, the one who identifies the
convoy, the border of the country  But a lot of people are there to decorate the convoy for the
soldiers deployed or for the soldiers ready to protect the country, that is, the
soldiers who are still lying there to protect the country, that is,
brother, now we are
pampering them, it is so small because in
1961  In the war which was the Hindi-Indo-China
war, there were very few troops in it,
now we fought together for a very long time, then
they had given the call, brother, we are sacrificing ourselves
for this country, but now you have to come forward,
now you who are our soldiers.  Those who are ready,
now here you come, continue this convoy.
Okay, so the option is the right answer. Okay, let's get
cut off in the sentence. Sir, ours. Now, for
whom is our address used?
Brother,
then
who is the option used for? Ours got cut off, sir.
Ours.  So, if there is no sorrow then sir, for the
soldiers sacrificing themselves to protect our country, for the soldiers getting
injured to protect the country, for the
soldiers guarding the borders of the country or for the country's downfall brother option
A is the right answer ok to protect the country.
It is okay for the soldiers to sacrifice themselves
because our heads are cut off. I am doing good.
If it were a soldier, then it is okay for myself, for him,
for the soldiers.
What kind of thing has been said in the line that sacrifices should not be made, brother mantra.  If we had
followed the path of non-violence to protect the land, then it would have happened, otherwise there would have been
no war. Everyone would have come and gone after listening to our sermon. But
where should we
go to the borders to protect the motherland? Next question number 10, which is
about this in the big market.  There is a page of your diary
where you must have read it. Let us
look at its questions and
what things have been said because we have
read this passage. We all know that the
page of the diary which was given in the Bade of Kolkata is
there.  For the first time, Independence Day was celebrated,
OK, and flags were put up in every house, so
you know the story. And to
stop the gathering, the flag was put up by the
commissioners of that time and the
British government of that time.  The
police who were there are all management people,
this meeting should not be a story, it should not be successful in any way, otherwise there will be a
rebellion, so let
us see
brother, let us see the management of the horse riders
from the side of the police administration, look in the option
here.
Flags were put up in every part of Kolkata.
Manoj used to go through this route. There
seemed to be excitement and novelty in this route. People
said that they have seen many such decorations.
Police was also scouring the city with all its might.
Okay, so what is the question asking?
Who made the arrangements for the house? So
brother, the police. Look, now
who made the arrangements for the invasion here? So brother, the police did it. Okay, so
this is the right answer. Let's move to the next
question. The houses in the big market are increasing.
What was the reason for decorating them and hoisting the national flag on them, then what was the reason, brother, the
anniversary of the Independence Day was to be celebrated, you will
see in the seconds of the text book
and those who are going to make it will celebrate with great pomp, they were going to
repeat this, that is,  It
was the second anniversary which was
written in the page of the diary. Which part was said about
celebrating the second anniversary. Okay, so
this is the right answer. Essence, innovation, communication among the people, brother, this
harvest, this region and among its elders,
brother, will you celebrate the birthday first or happiness first?
Why will you celebrate the first birthday? Brother,
secondly, if you are next in line, then you will
celebrate his birthday, then
in what context, what questions are you asking,
what was the reason for hoisting the national flag, that is, the second anniversary of the country's independence.  Must
admit that now
while celebrating its anniversary, we were feeling happy.
Naveen is talking about the matter. Okay, so what was
Karan, this was Karan. The
feeling of patriotism also got awakened later.
Let's tell the
story in the city. Why was there no traffic police?
Why was there no traffic police earlier?  It is said that brother, the
traffic police was under patrolling,
this is true because they were
arrested all the time from Chowrangi Road to
Dharmatalla and from the entire market
because they had to
stop the protest that was going to take place.  That's
why the
officers there had said that you should
not let this happen,
deploy all the police, that is why there was
traffic there, otherwise the police,
what were the traffic police even doing?
Also, there is a police, they also
started patrolling that day, there
was no traffic in the city, so brother, this is wrong, the traffic
police were celebrating the independence day, this is also
wrong, the traffic police was abolished,
this is also wrong.  So Option A Right Answer I think
you guys have written the same answer
Right let's do the
question number now
Motor
Jo Sajan is deployed at every mode of every city as per the government order to stop the violence during Gorki and Sajan program.  The
government was not
going to go to the element unless its senior officers give orders to it. No police is going to
come from my side or yours.
Brother, if the police barricade
any area, then its superior officers
will intimate it brother.  You go there and
wait for this thing.
This Gorakh and Sajjan were deployed here to do their duty fearlessly as per government order. Okay, make
arrangements for the meeting to be held in the evening.
Now brother, make arrangements, that is,
make some arrangements.  They were
attending the meeting to be held in the evening, now they were invited a little,
they did not have the rock to
protest, okay, so option B is the right answer,
although you must be understanding everything,
now one question to understand all the questions and answers to all the questions.  Also comes reasoning
which says that statement one says that the police
took away a large number of parks and grounds. This is correct. Brother, what did the police do
in large numbers? What did they
take away from the park? That is why the police did not complete its work.  She was
protesting by giving force to the city,
this is also correct. Okay, so
here the first statement A and Karan and
both brothers are correct
but Karan is also wrong. This is also not an option.
Statement A is correct but Karan and  The
bike is misinterpreting it. Statement A is correct, the
second one is wrong, if not, the second one is also correct.
Let's say, now only this is the matter, one mantra option is given.
Statement A and Karan and both are correct and Karan
R is what it is, that is, the police with their full strength.  He is
protesting by giving guests in the city, for
what reason is he doing it and to
cordon off the grounds, that is why he is doing it OK, there is only
one correct explanation
question which is a long question, here we will
see and here we will answer two questions.
Children, the
thing you have to give is to pay a lot of
attention to cleanliness. Okay, so the first question was that
now, on the basis of the lesson about being saddened by the suffering of others,
write that the author's mother is an activist for
environmental protection.  What was the punishment
and what kind of punishment did she say? Brother, do
not tease any animal or bird in the evening, do
not pluck flowers, pay obeisance to a river,
that is,
you should protect the environment from all the things that are related to the environment.  She
was a conscious minister, so he always used to
understand his son, brother, don't do this, do
n't do that, okay, this is the other one
and why was he repeatedly requesting the rich people to
complete the song, brother,
why was he doing it
because his song was so good.  She was sweet and
in this song, she was completely dubbed after
hearing her voice. Okay, that's why
I keep listening, you stay at the gate, I keep
listening.
What was the specialty in her personality?
Who was there in her personality in Agra to complete the song?  What specialty was
emerging brother? What special thing was emerging,
so it is necessary that I
see this as good for you, so the role of a good was
emerging. Okay, next question, why is there moisture
in the behavior of the elder brother towards the younger brother?
Brother, why did she come now? So
in the beginning you must have read that the elder brother
always scolds the elder brother, what do the elder brothers do to the
younger brother,
brother, don't say here, don't do that there, make a timeline time
table, you should know about your very own.  In joy,
he used to guide his brother in some way or the other,
brother, don't do this, don't do this, come home on time, you had to
study day and night, now what were you to
study, while studying, he used to make something or the other, laugh etc.,
but whatever he made  Yes,
no one was able to understand, it
happened that the younger brother used to play
but also had to study but not as much
as the elder brother had to study, put oil in his eyes day and night.
Now he had to study but he could
understand
when the exam came.  When the result came, the
younger brother passed and the elder brother failed, then
when such an incident happened for the second time, then when he
failed again for the second time, then his
behavior started becoming moist
and when the moisture came,  The younger brother also started
taking a little advantage. Okay, so this was it. Let's
answer two questions from the passage here on the basis of the read poem. You must have
answered the two questions which you found easy. On the
basis of the read poem,
Kabir in relation to speech.  On the thoughts of brother, now
what was said about speech,
speak sweet words, mother,
you should write the full explanation of
what happens when you speak sweet words, the simple
way of explaining this is that the question has been twisted a bit instead of
asking directly.  What is
asked here, brother, on the basis of the poem read, throw
light on the poet's thoughts regarding speech, that
is, what Kabir ji has
said to him in the couplet, 'Speak such speech, mother,
you, someone had written its complete explanation and
in its elder part.  Had to write. Let's
see the next question. Take the idea in the poem 'Humanity'
that 'Why do you die?
What message did the poet want to convey to the readers? So
here is what is in this part in the chapter 'Humanity':
Poet 'Humanity' In the lesson 'Humanity', the poet said that '
You are going to do but
What should you do before doing anything? There are many
good things in life, you should do less if you kill, then
kill in such a way that your death becomes the death of the world,
your death becomes dust in the world, that is,
people should name you and not abuse you. Let
this happen in your life.
Before you do anything in life, this is the world of death and
whoever comes here should do something good and
go. We may leave this world but
our works and our creations will
always be remembered.  If you
die, never be afraid to do it.
Okay, there is no need to be afraid of doing it.
You must do good. You must do charity.
Help people and
not look at your own interests. Okay, so
you gave all these messages. Whatever message was humanity.  Whatever
messages you might have received in the lesson, you had to write them down
while studying or whatever you read which was given
by your teacher. Come here, on the
basis of Mountain State Powers,
write where have the Sal trees gone? Brother,
where have the Sal trees gone?
So, what happened here in the mountain region, when the
forests got more flooded, the forests started getting more flooded, the rain started falling
continuously that it was not
visible from above, then what happened when the rain started
becoming continuous and started falling there, there was
a smoke like smoke here.  The dust
started rising and what happened in the dust of dust,
this whole atmosphere which was like a creeper here, there are
no trees here, now the whole atmosphere seems to have
become a cloud. Okay, here it seems
that all the years that were slaves are gone. Story  But
okay,
this was question number 13, it was related to your collection
lesson, symbols of faith, religious
institutions
inspire human beings to walk on the right path in life, in the
context of the story, in
favor or against this statement i.e. in favor of.  Is it for or
in opposition? The answer should have been given in a
logical manner. That is, what has been said brother,
religion is a symbol of faith. Today you have seen that
we all have faith in our religious institution. Let
us go to the position of many Babas.
These Babas.  If they start looting us, then the
same thing was told in this part in the lesson as well, in
every form, because whatever
Thakurs there used to do the same thing to the valley, the
Mahants there used to do the same thing only to stop the innocent people from taking
their lands.  If we wanted to grab our
property and increase our property in Thakurwadi's courtyard,
then even today the
same thing is happening in the society.
You must have seen it, then
we should keep these buttons for or against,
then what should we do?  Brother,
we should have hope,
one doctor makes a mistake, that means all the doctors will be
wrong, we cannot do this, so
we should have faith, but when we
feel that our trust has been
taken advantage of, then we should understand ourselves and
not be completely blind.
We all know what is right and what is wrong
because we all are educated, so there is
no need to study much in the name of Baba,
that Baba is good who serves you selflessly.
Such Baba is the right person for you
who does not seem like a Baba.
Stay away from such people who are taking you, no matter which religion they
are, okay, this is the thing, in the pros and cons,
write on the basis of the lesson, to
what extent do you consider the life of Master Pritam and the teachers to be sacrificed and justified?
Why see the asterisk in the opposition,
you have to understand why teachers like Pritam, Pritam Chandra and others should be
celebrated,
brother,
nowadays the time is not such that you can
harass anyone all day long and because today's
education has become very cloudy,
okay today's.  Beating is not allowed in education.
Okay, but it has also been said that
patting is necessary to make a brother stand.
I would say that I do not support that every
teacher is giving permission to beat teachers.
No, there should be only as much Chhath as the
dab of the button should be with love. In this way, the
potter has to put his hand inside the stand and
tap the marker from outside because unless
he taps it from outside, the pot will
not be ready.  We should understand these things,
so I would like that the teacher's
teeth are also important and the teacher does
not have any such work. The teacher does not have the right to
treat any child mercilessly. Okay,
loving feelings are also a big thing. Okay,
but there is a fear.  There should be no fear in the mother of every child, I would call it
respect, we should fear it,
you all love your parents,
mother, you are respected by yourself, if there is
no fear, then there is no fear, there
should be respect, okay here teachers
and students  Both of them definitely have a role.
Let's look at the problems of Topi Shukla, the hero of the lesson Topi Shukla.
How would you like to improve the education system?
Brother, who is the hero of Topi Shukla,
what improvement would you like to bring in the education system here?
You must have read,
whoever is looking at today's education system
which needs improvement, you
can write your views, here your
views will be accepted by all and you will be
given proper meaning, keep it on the right side, but ok, I
hope this is  Out of the questions, you must have
written well out of the three. Now let us move on.
Here is a
sweet word on the title of Ekalavya in about 100 words. It is a
very good thing. Had to create a story on a sweet word and it is a very good
topic. Sweet words.  This means that you
could have written a story. Along with that,
you were given the name of Manav or Manavyan.
You have bought a television online and
now you have extended assurance warranty for it. What is the meaning of the
warranty and what is the
meaning of the accident and  If you want to extend it, if you want to
get the facility, then
sometimes it happens that you brother, if we
buy a product, then one calls and
becomes a customer,
then you want to extend your warranty period,
get detailed information in this regard.  While doing
receive an email to Lakhni how can we get it in the
big Let's see next
here what is here now we are seeing the
paragraph was given paragraph which
is very good it was asked ok
in the big of indigenous production i.e.  Local on Tone
If you would have read this second weight
then perhaps you could have answered it that indigenous
production is the basis of development which if we
adopt indigenous things i.e. Indian things then the development of our country will further progress and
we will move ahead in the world.  If we go
to this, everyone from the Government of India to ours is
emphasizing on this, then a
paragraph has been given on this, in which you did
not have to do anything, here you had to do a
question form for each signal point, what to do.
If you make a question form in your mind
and
write two sentences each on the basis of each point, perhaps I think
you will be able to write the complete answer, like
I say, is it indigenous production, is it
indigenous production, what brother,
I have written the question form.  What is indigenous production
? If you give priority to the things made in your city or your country
or the things made in your village,
that is
called indigenous production. Okay, that was a simple sentence.
Secondly, why is it necessary? Brother, today
our
economy is  There
is definitely a big need for indigenous production in India because if we buy things from outside countries
like China,
then somehow we are
weakening our country because
our money is going to other countries, that is
why we have to  What we need is that we should promote
our things so that the money of our country
stays in our country and promote our things
so that the external money reaches us.
Okay,
after that comes the third
impact on the Indian economy, so this is what I have
completed, Indian.  How will the economy be
affected because the external things,
our things, will go out or if we use
more of our things, then the
external Colgate, the external products
of China will reduce, now the country which
is showing arrogance on us, the country which we  But he is showing his eyes, that
is, we are the biggest
market in the world. We are in the biggest market in the world. Will
anyone come and show us to our country?
Brother, we have sacrificed what we have for the world to
move our country forward.
We
should adopt the things of our country to uplift ourselves. This is the
right answer. What is the
suggestion? Brother, you can give a simple suggestion in this that
I have been following these things since yesterday,
you too have adopted these things for the
third second.  It was
also a very good paragraph that the basis of education on self-congratulation and discipline was the
question form here, so perhaps its
answers could have been written very easily. The last one is '
Beti Bachao Beti Padhao'. A very good
topic was given but you  You can write a lot of things
which you can read about
why daughters should have that child,
what is the need of it in our country in the present times and what is its impact on the society.
You could have written many things for this, let's go.  We move ahead
Next
Your city resident Mohan Raina Mohan Rahna or
Mohni Rahna Okay, you had to write a letter to the
Municipal Corporation in about 100 words drawing attention to the problem arising from water logging in your area,
so I hope you
all wrote.  So son, what
happens here is that many people have a relief in their mind that if I
write in the service, then brother, whatever has already been done,
you can start from the service also,
even by paying money, okay then it is the
beginning from the service because if  What is the Municipal Corporation? If it is
given by hand in your city, then
what should you do? Brother, in the service. After that, you
had to write to those to whom you are writing. After that, whatever
peas were given in the question paper for whom,
brother, it is getting waterlogged.  In your city, you have to
inform the Municipal Corporation that water logging is happening, for this
now pay attention and do
something about it. Okay, you had
written a request for this. Next, what was the
city resident study? Is there any study or study
in the park of your area till now?  It is being used as a dustbin
in your area. It is not a park but will be a dustbin.
What are all the people doing by coming and
dumping the garbage there?
Here also you have to write a letter to the Municipal Corporation, so the
format is the same, both are very  Good letters
were given, perhaps if you have written then
you will receive very good. Let's
second assume that you are Bhupendra Nautiyal or Bhopal
L and here you will see that all the
letters that were given to the children, whatever email was given, the
name was definitely given here.  Your name is here, this is the
name you have to use,
you guys have come very good, this
game is from Sachin of Student Council of Anugrah Secondary School, OK, create a box for information giving the details of the
football training camp to be organized in the school.
And above or
below the story, information must have been written,
no problem, it will be good, brother, who is the one to give the information?
So Secondary School, Anugrah
Secondary School, we will
write the information, what will we write about the subject,
organization of football training camp,
OK, these are the words you had to write,
after that you write.  Where do you want to call, you
prepare an information second which is b which is
you Romila Tinku Romila Tinku and the
president or superintendent of the NGO Mila
organization want to give scholarship to the student for excellent performance in Khelo
OK that means Jo Khelo
What are you doing to give scholarship to the students for their good performance in sports, that is,
you were going to be given
something for Chhath, okay dear, to
give information about this to the general public, you had to prepare a notice in 80 words.
Okay,
you got a notice for the scholarship.  There
is a government institution to prepare, let's take
question number 18 from its side, which is
Question number 18, which is from whose side the
Environment Ministry is responsible for creating awareness among the common people about the negative impact of the production of single-use plastic.
And brother, prepare
an attractive advertisement in about 60 words on behalf of the Environment Ministry.
Okay, the advertisement
had to be prepared and who is the person giving the advertisement.
Below I had to write to you who is the
Environment Ministry, what was it for? Brother, the
use of plastic i.e. the bag which is in
it.  It was very simple to make, then the
name of a company named Nishant Rashmi, a solar heater manufacturing company, was given
and the task was to prepare an attractive advertisement in about 60 words for publicity.  That
is, if you
liked the cold season now, then thank you, so many
people joined the match, thank you, thank you, thank you to everyone.